y en directo a Vamos hasta Ecuador donde
conectamos con nuestro enviado especial
Rodrigo sedano para conversar sobre una
jornada cargada de noticias allí en el
país andino Rodrigo muy buenas noches el
presidente Guillermo lasso habló hoy a
todo el país y defendió la llamada
muerte Cruzada a la medida con la que
disolvió la asamblea nacional qué más
dijo el mandatario cuéntenos
Andrés muy buenas noches También para ti
pues lo que ha hecho hoy Guillermo lasso
ha aparecido casi el primer acto de
campaña para estas elecciones
anticipadas después de esa muerte
Cruzada ha empezado hablando de una
batalla que sucedió hace 200 años la
batalla de pichincha que dio lugar a la
independencia del Ecuador para después
hacer un alegato muy duro contra la
oposición esa oposición que le llevó a
juicio político por presunto delito de
peculado ha dicho que lo que han traído
es el golpismo al país al Ecuador para
después hacer un repaso de los que ha
considerado sus principales logros de
estos dos años que se cumplían hoy
precisamente de gobierno de Guillermo
lasso ha hablado de logros en educación
de logros en sanidad y también por
supuesto hablado de logros en materia de
seguridad Pero ha habido muchas críticas
a este discurso porque se ha entendido
que ha sido un discurso alejado de la
realidad que vive la mayoría del pueblo
ecuatoriano en las de Quito donde nos
encontramos desde hace varios días el
sentir general es que el país ha crecido
en inseguridad y que el gobierno no ha
sabido hacer lo suficiente para
conseguir bajar esos niveles de
inseguridad sobre todo en la costa en
Guayaquil y en la provincia de
esmeraldas una provincia de esmeraldas
en donde Guillermo lasso ha sacado pecho
de lo que se ha conseguido Ya llevan más
de un mes con apenas muertes allá
también ha dicho que se ha conseguido
que va a aumentar el número de policías
se va a aumentar el número de chalecos y
de armas que tengan a su disposición ha
dicho Guillermo lasso que defiende esta
muerte Cruzada porque él cree que es la
mejor manera de darle al pueblo
ecuatoriano la capacidad de que decidan
las urnas sobre el futuro del país sobre
si debe seguir Un gobierno de Guillermo
lasso o debe llegar la oposición ha sido
muy crítico además con el correísmo ha
dicho que fueron unos gobiernos muy
corruptos que lo que ha conseguido ahora
su gobierno es que bajando esa
corrupción y bajando también el déficit
fiscal del país han conseguido hacer más
infraestructuras pero de nuevo las
infraestructuras son uno de los puntos
clave la gente cree que han empeorado
ahora en el país lo único usted
mencionaba hace un momento que empieza
una especie de campaña Y es que ya se
conoce la fecha desde las elecciones
anticipadas y hay incertidumbres sobre
si lazo volverá a presentarse que hay
que decir al respecto
pues Andrés ahora mismo es una de las
grandes preguntas que se hace todo el
mundo aquí en Ecuador Se volverá a
presentarlas o sí o no a France 24 nos
han dicho desde el gobierno en una
entrevista que nada es descartable pero
es cierto que el tono hoy del presidente
sí que sonaba un poco a despedida ha
sido un tono muy solemne el de Guillermo
lasso y tampoco ha dejado en claro si Se
volverá a presentar o no a estas
elecciones unas elecciones de las que
por cierto ya sabemos la fecha será el
próximo 20 de agosto en ese momento se
votarán además unas votaciones populares
sobre si habrá que seguir con
extracciones petrolíferas y de minerales
en dos reservas naturales del país ahora
empiezan unos plazos muy concretos muy
cortos para estas elecciones tan solo
habrá una semana antes de la votación
para que los candidatos hagan campaña